عدد قتل زلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
يتجاوز الخمسه الاف بروده الطقس تعرقل
الوصول للعالقين تحت الانقاب بتركيا
والكشف عن اعراض يشعر بها الجسم قبل وقوع
زلزال هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في حصيله جديده لكارثه الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا اعلنت اداره الكوارث التركيه اليوم
الثلاثاء ارتفاع عدد الضحايا الزلزال الى
اكثر من
340 قتيلا وحوالي 22 اصابه اما في سوريا
فاعلن المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 1620 شخصا واصابه
الالاف في عموم مناطق البلاد فيما تشير
تقديرات لمنظمه الصحه العالميه الى ان
قرابه 20,000 شخص لقوا مصرعهم نتيجه زلزال
المدمر والعشرات في الهزات الارتداديه
في تركيا تحديدا افادت وسائل اعلام بان
بروده الطقس تعرق الوجود فرق الانقاذ في
البحث عن عالقنا تحت الانقاض تقارير اوضحت
ان المدن التي ضربها الزلزال مثل ما لاتيا
وكرما مرعش وغزي عنتاب وديار بكر تشهد
بروده شديده وتساقطا للامطار والثلوج مع
اقتراب درجات الحراره من الصفر فيما قال
مختصون ان على عمال الانقاذ ان يتحركوا
بسرعه لانه من الضروري انقاذ العالقين تحت
الانقاض في ظرف اثنتين وسبعين ساعه وهي
المده المعروفه للبقاء على قيد الحياه تحت
الانقاض في ظروف الطقس القصير
[موسيقى]
وفيما تستمر جهود الالقاب على مدار الساعه
للبحث عن عائقين واخراجهم من المناطق
السوريه ايضا اعلنت الامم المتحده ان
الزلزاله يعطل تدفق المساعدات من تركيا
الى سوريا متحدثه باسم الامم المتحده
اوضحت ان تدفق المساعدات المهمه التي
تنقلها المنظمه من تركيا الى شمال غرب
سوريا توقف مؤقتا بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت
بالطرق ومشاكل اللوجستيه اخرى مرتبطه
بالزلزال العنيف دون وجود اي معلومات عن
موعد استئنافها فيما تشير المنظمه الى ان
اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال غرب
سوريا يعتمدون على المساعدات القادمه عبر
الحدود
وفي تصريح صادم افادت منظمه الصحه
العالميه الثلاثاء بان عدد المتضررين
بزلزال المدمر الذي اودى بحياه الالاف في
تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى اكثر من 20 مليون
مسؤوله بارزه في المنظمه اوضحت ان خريطه
الاحداث تظهر ان عدد الذين يحتمل ان
يكونوا تاثروا بالزلزال يبلغ ثلاثه وعشرين
مليونا بينهم نحو خمسه ملايين في وضع ضعف
فيما قال مدير ربما تدرس اذن نحن في سباق
مع الزمن مع تزايد اعداد ضحايا الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا وتضاءل فرص العثور على
ناجينا احياء
وفي خبرنا الاخير نشرت مجله ناتشرال هيلبس
العلميه تقريرا قالت فيه ان هناك اعراضا
جسديه قد يشعر بها الانسان وتنذر بقرب
وقوع الزلزال ومن ابرز هذه الاعراض هو
الصداع والغثيان او الدوران الى جانب
الشعور بالضيق والقلق وعدم القدره على ضبط
النفس بالاضافه الى تغيرات مؤقته بالرؤيه
وطنين بالاذن اللافت ان التعليقات الكثير
من الاشخاص على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تحدثت عن اعراض غريبه شعروا بها قبل وقوع
الكارثه من بينها شعور بالصداع والدوار
وضيق التنفس
[موسيقى]